green collar jobs are to us the way we
define green collar jobs is that it's a
job that has a net benefit to the
environment so it can be something that
a PhD does in terms of designing a
hybrid car but it can also be something
as simple you know as the guy or the gal
that actually is working to maintain the
urban forest you know planting a green
roof you know installing a solar panel
those are also environmental green
collar jobs that pay back you know not
only to the person that does the work
which is great but also to the
environment because it's actually
reducing you know some of the
environmental costs that we continuously
pay as a result of global warming